my central for industry ball along with
all of that great great ball on the
baseline he had no place to go and
that's the first good time that Paul
Martin put a finger and a hand in stiff
Kurt partly set for his face he took
objection to that security coming in
players remaining on their respective
benches but James capers moves in
[Applause]
this is claim this is Game seven there's
so much pressure here we're not allowing
this this is this is down the park okay
this is a great move right there I take
the file right he's busy dribbling now
over here you don't need that I don't
care what happened with the guy down on
the floor you don't need to push him
away because something is gonna happen
how you could see right there he got
popped
[Applause]
so games paper said more and son right
gonna sort this out and we're gonna not
I said get a little foul out of it
somewhere wait to cheat right there they
say you don't need that you don't need
to the push across there's no reason for
that now you've got you know you're
going and you're not got it now if you
should win or this goes Game seven you
know he will probably be suspended if
they make this a flagrant situation